[MUSIC]
As the last notes of my
violin fell upon the crowd,
the audience burst into applause.
I had just finished the best violin
performance in my life today and
I was feeling awesome.
I ran off the stage, up to my mom,
expecting praise, compliments, hugs.
Instead, I was greeted with an unenthused
high five, and a, see Helen,
if you just apply yourself like
this to other aspects of your life,
think about how awesome you could be.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But that hurt,
because her opinion mattered a lot to me.
And I'm not sharing the story with you,
to ask for your pity or because I enjoy
throwing my poor mom under the bus.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But because I can trace a lot of
my inability to give or
receive good compliments,
to my strict traditional Chinese heritage.
But you don't have to come from the same
upbringing to maybe also struggle
with giving or receiving compliments.
And because I'm an ex-consultant,
I'm going to have you guys take a look at
a chart.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Take a look at this chart, and
take a moment and think about maybe
where you fall on this chart.
I'm willing to bet, if I took a poll,
most of you guys would say,
[SOUND] somewhere in the middle.
But I'm also willing to bet a lot
of us actually unknowingly fall
into this bottom left-hand corner.
Somewhere between not being so
great at giving compliments and
not being so great at receiving them.
And today, I'm here to not only get us
up to that upper right-hand corner,
>> [LAUGH]
>> But to also drive home the importance
of being in that corner starting
with giving compliments
Think about the last time you
gave someone a compliment.
What did you say?
How specific or
genuine do you think it was?
When was it?
I ask these questions because a lot of us,
again,
don't realize how few
good compliments we give.
And there's a lot of good reasons for
that.
For example, thanks to the illusion of
transparency, we believe that other
people know how we think, or
know what we feel, and that's not true.
Other times, we're just trying
to avoid being awkward, so
we don't say anything at all.
And even worse,
sometimes we're a little self-absorbed.
And so, we forget about the people
around us as we really focus on what
we're trying to get done,
what we're trying to do.
But stick with me here, because there's
really good reasons as to why we need to
become better complimenters.
Starting with the fact that giving
a good compliment actually drives
achievement at a very fundamental level.
Researchers in Japan recently discovered
that giving someone a good compliment is
equivalent to giving them straight cash.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And yes,
I'm a poor grad student right now so
I love money.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But this actually, like any reward,
leaves us wanting more.
It drives us to want to recreate
our stellar performance.
Giving an awesome compliment is also
better than giving constructive criticism.
This coming from a researcher
at the University of Hamburg.
Where he noted that giving a good
compliment exacerbates our optimism bias.
We have a feeling and we believe that good
things will happen and bad things won't.
[LAUGH] So, when we give a good compliment
or we receive a good compliment.
We then believe that we
can actually achieve and
do something that maybe we
wouldn't have otherwise.
And finally,
giving a good compliment lifts moods,
it builds trust, and
it leads to stronger relationships.
And the simple act of just
recognizing those around you,
builds the foundations of reciprocity and
positivity.
That leads to long lasting relationships.
With all that being said in order to
actually achieve all of these benefits you
actually have to give a good compliment.
So what's a good compliment?
It comes down to giving the content and
having great delivery.
When it comes down to content,
we're thinking about being specific.
What exactly does someone do
to deserve that compliment?
When we're specific, we avoid
comparing people to each other, and
we also show that we were
really paying attention.
We also want to be achievement focused.
We want to think about what they
achieved versus what someone is.
Because when we think about achievement
and we talk about achievement,
it's something someone can repeat and
someone can do better.
It's what triggers that
reward center in their brain.
Now when it comes to delivery, what we
want to talk about is being genuine.
And the easiest way to do that is
to just recognize the impact that
someone had on you.
And finally, we want to be selective.
As much as you guys might walk away from
this talk saying you get a compliment, you
get a compliment, you get a compliment.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We want to avoid doing that,
because when you give
too many compliments,
that compliment and
that sincerity, gets diluted.
Okay, so now that you guys are all
awesome at giving compliments.
Walk with me to the other side,
as we talk about receiving compliments.
When was the last time someone
gave you a compliment?
How did you react?
Was it potentially with a question mark,
like [SOUND] thanks?
Was it maybe with a no, no,
no it wasn't me it was the team.
It was the weather.
It was luck.
>> [LAUGH]
>> These reactions are so
common that sociolinguists have
categorized them into two categories,
rejection and deflection.
And there is a good reason why,
>> [LAUGH]
>> We also tend to dodge, dip, duck, dive,
and dodge compliments like
we're playing dodgeball.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And
it all starts from when we were kids.
We're told that good people and
strong leaders are humble.
So we don't want to come off as stuck up.
We also have a tendency to
run away from the spotlight.
So when someone shines the bright
light of praise on us,
our first reaction is to run away.
And finally, especially in this room,
we all tend to be a little self-critical,
some of us very self-critical.
And when someone gives us a compliment
we view it with skepticism.
What did we even do to deserve it?
And this last part is really important,
because when we dodge a good compliment.
We're actually devaluing the perspective,
the time,
the heart, that someone put
into giving us that compliment.
And just as much as giving good
compliments builds up relationships,
dodging good compliments breaks
those relationships down.
Additionally, when we dodge
compliments we're also
missing out on an awesome
opportunity to better ourselves.
We did something to really
deserve that compliment.
Figuring out what that is will make
us better and stronger, faster.
So when it comes to receiving compliments,
there's really just two pieces.
Acknowledge, just say thank you.
You're going to want to say more,
but just stop at thank you.
Internalize, really think about what
you did to deserve that compliment.
And how you could recreate that, and how
you could apply it elsewhere in your life.
Now admittedly as I stand in front of you
giving you all this sage advice on giving
compliments and receiving them.
I myself continue to really struggle with
becoming a better compliment giver and
receiver, it's hard.
But just the other day, I was
teaching my seven year old nephew how
to throw a frisbee, and memories of that
violin recital came flooding back to me.
And I wondered what I would have
wanted my mom to say in that moment.
And I was reminded that this was my
opportunity to not repeat history.
So I countered each of his throws with
a very specific targeted compliment.
And I watched as his confidence grew,
I saw it in his eyes,
and to think that I could have that
kind of an impact on a young child.
Was a stark reminder that my work,
that our work in becoming
better compliment givers and
receivers is never done.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]